Peter Schrager NFL Network Fox Sports
and part of the emmy-nominated good
morning football which airs Monday
through Friday 7:00 a.m. Eastern
Thursday night football continues this
week Eagles Panthers CBS NFL Network
Amazon Prime video good have you in
studio great to be here this is so cool
you went to Indianapolis this past
weekend for the Colts Niners did you
have any idea what was going on with the
vice president I was a sideline reporter
for Fox Sports so I'm worried about
Marlin max hip you know I'm doing good
in there the big storyline is that Ryan
Kelly's back in the lineup for the Colts
but this all happens now the Secret
Service was there and we did a thorough
check with them now the interesting deal
that no one else is talking about is
that this was such a cool weekend for
Peyton like such a cool weekend that
Edgerrin James they haven't seen him in
years he's their Marvin Harrison comes
in the entire starting lineup from that
unit and if I'm Jim Irsay and I'm flying
all these guys in I'm having this great
festivities the entire fan bases - and
the headline coming out of that is vice
president storms I'm curious because the
vice president knew going in that the
49ers were gonna be doing some sort of
demonstration that was no great surprise
the Niners have announced that so I'd be
curious to hear Payton's thoughts I'd be
curious I hear Jim Irsay's thoughts you
put on this great event and the big
headline is the vice president leaving
you have Peyton there they're honoring
Peyton and I couldn't help but think
what's going on threw in Andrew Luck's
mind as he's watching all of this and
wondering if one day he gets this kind
of tribute there but at now they say
they're gonna they're gonna plain when
he gets healthy but is there a
break-even point with them that okay we
have to play them because we're sort of
in this or do they shut him down a
couple weird factors with that so I get
to go to the practice if you do the
sidelines you get to go to the practice
on Friday and see everything with no
cameras and the media the local guys
aren't allowed to be there so I'm
watching Andrew Luck practice one of the
three people me Spielman and Brennaman
and we're watching him and he's not
doing live action drills he's going
throwing on air but it's like five ten
yards it's not he's a long ways away and
he's not ready to go next week I'd be
very surprised if we see one excuse on
the flip side of it they haven't played
a team in the AFC yet they haven't
played anyone into the division yet that
divisions so wide open and per sets won
a couple games so it's one of these
deals where let's see how the season
goes and if per sets winning football
games and we've got something going here
and there's good juju maybe
just leave them out the rest of the
season I'd be curious with you he wants
to play the team wants to see him play
obviously Chuck Pagano we don't know
what his job said it's gonna be at the
end of the season he probably wants to
see Andrew Luck play but from what I saw
it's not gonna be in the next seven to
ten days that we see him in the field
yeah but how did they screw this up that
they were this far off of him playing
this season this isn't even close how
much worse could it have been they could
have gone with told Xena and not pull
the trigger on Brissette when they're
lucky to have Bruce a they made a move
that you know Phillip Dorsett wasn't
doing anything they get Brissette and
suddenly they've got a guy that thinks
that they think could be a starting
quarterback in the NFL but yeah you have
to wonder they go through the entire
draft process the entire free agency
process no back-up plan really for luck
and what we were hearing at the start of
training camp was that he was throwing
it tennis ball hadn't even thrown a
football Mitchell true Biscay last night
and know that we you know we have to
have this reaction we got to jump in
here's my hot take and Mitchell to
risky's the franchise there I still
haven't seen enough obviously I think
the preseason kind of raised the bar I
expected him to be really good last
night he wasn't but there's enough there
that I saw mobility what they did with
the pocket with him they had penalties
and drop passes but it looked like he
knew what he he looked like a starting
quarterback not a franchise quarterback
but his starting quarterback what is
your litmus test where you go okay now I
got a pretty good idea of how good this
guy is you know Watson started that
first game in Cincinnati I'm like four
days rest and did next to nothing
through the air I made that one play and
won the game and everyone's like well
yeah no he looked the part and there was
juice that's how I look at it the juice
the building was alive they're coming
off that Cubs win everyone was excited
and Kendall right after the game said
yeah there's definitely an it factor
there's something there Glennon is a
nice kid I sound like I'm being
degrading to Glenn a nice guy
can play in the NFL but this is the it
factor and when they trade it up to get
risky I think a lot of Bears fans were
outraged by that over like why would we
do that we just got Glennon I think you
see why now there's a succession plan
there's a future I think true Biscay has
it and it's gonna be interesting to
watch you talk about the 2011 draft
Watson mahomes true Biscay Kaiser how
are we gonna chart these guys in next
few years I think sure risky's in the
least advantageous situation doesn't
have a number one receiver I think
that's the 32nd wide receivers room in
the league like I don't think there's no
any NFL starting talent in Chicago
at receiver I want to see how true
Biscay develops knowing that he hasn't
have the weapons at the other guys do
who feels like the worst team in the NFL
just as with the Niners for a while
doesn't feel that way
they're upbeat they've lost four games
in a row by a total of 11 points the
defense is good defense is good Browns
they're so young
the Giants feel like the worst team in
the NFL that's that because there's
expectations of Super Bowl and and then
that it gets away real quickly once
you're a team that thinks you're a bunch
of veterans and you need let's start off
on four on five on six it can get real
ugly and I wonder if you're the Giants
now you got to bring in wide receivers
you're gonna have you know casting coal
here for wide receivers
they want to be in a position I to get a
shot at a quarterback I'm a guest with
Eli no matter what happens this year it
feels like they'd be in the market for a
quarterback it's not imprudent right I
mean I feel like they got Davis Webb in
the third round or fourth round and
people were saying all right let's see
how it does
Geno Smith's there but I think you don't
get a top five pick every interview the
Giants are the franchise you don't
expect to every 20 years you know so
when you have that pick I think you f go
quarterback and think succession plan
the Chiefs last year traded up and got
mahomes doesn't mean Alex Smith isn't
going to start the season doesn't mean
if anything Moe Holmes has lit a fire
under Alex Smith Alex what's playing the
best football of his career
I think he's seen the script before with
Kaepernick I wonder if they were to
draft a quarterback in the top five will
there be a Darnell DeRozan a Josh Allen
does that elevate Eli's game next year
hey there's actually a fire burning now
I've got to play them better and be
better well I don't know it'd have to be
a fire five-alarm fire to ignite eli
there yeah you know we have che and
Irving who calls in he calls him sling
blade
yeah I love that nickname for free you
know what Slingblade wins two Super
Bowls because he's just Billy Bob is
just straight you see a hall-of-famer he
is you see a hall-of-famer because okay
you beat the Patriots you went to Super
Bowls just that alone man you play in
New York and your last names Manning yes
you know I think Plunkett is the only
one to win to do it hasn't and you know
Eli's won two Super Bowls against Tom
Brady and he has done it at the biggest
stage is throwing his team on his back I
think Eli Manning is OK who goes in
first Ben or Eli back they both return
here's the litmus doesn't we I talked
about this with Kyle Brant who's one of
the co-hosts on the NFL Network show he
says if you have to think
he's not so here's one for it is Philip
Rivers a hall-of-famer you're thinking
about yeah not on I think so too
I think so too but like that's the
hesitation well we see these guys
everybody's gonna have numbers and the
numbers I think are skewed Brandon
Marshall Hall of Famer I don't think six
100 catch seems amazing player no
playoffs though you never had a playoff
game and I don't I think it's different
with quarterback and wider yeah I think
there's the rings matter with a
quarterback but you're gonna have guys
who are gonna be pedestrians putting up
50,000 you're right and it used to be
that was unheard of even 300 touchdown
passes was unheard such a fun debate cuz
who are the no-brainers that are
currently a quarterback right Brady
I think Rogers already I think Brees
already I think Roethlisberger already
and then there's a couple guys Rivers
and Manning that you're like and then
it's an interesting debate because not
everyone can get in from a generation
you know there has to be Kenny Anderson
can't get in you know there's always
that guy that's you know Phil Simms had
two Super Bowls also good player well he
didn't win this if he did win the second
one right then he's in the Hall of Fame
where are you this weekend this weekend
I got interesting when Detroit Lions New
Orleans Saints in the Big Easy
ooh Saints off a bye couple wins in a
row Lions coming in hobbled after that
loss of the Panthers are you surprised
the same student radiator and Peterson
to the Viking but but he's not doing
anything it's nice I did two Vikings
games in a row and I actually was like
there's no bad blood for Adrian Peterson
there but when Dalvin cook goes down you
have to think okay this is a perfect
trade like just make it yeah I think I
think that it's that bad yeah I think
it's done like final question and this
is tough and I know you're a man who
asks tough questions nothing who's
prettier
Kyle Brant or Kay Adams house pretty
good yeah I thought that's the writing I
love cave but yeah Kyle's got the jaw
line is closed it's closed yeah
good-looking guy he was in Days of Our
Lives yeah I heard
yeah I'm sure I'll tell you we
appreciate coming I love you love now be
on again Peter Schrager
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience